I have a bunch of apps on my my phone
right here and so apps for great thats
Delaware Attorney General Beau Biden the
son of Vice President Joe Biden he
doesn't think all smartphone apps are
that great there shouldn't be an app
that allow people to avoid law
enforcement effort to keep people safe
on the streets and an app that's
dedicated to having people be able to
avoid DUI checkpoints is simply not good
public policy and it's a danger to the
community Biden is talking about smart
phone apps such as trapster which lets
users know where cops have set up DUI
checkpoints Biden along with four US
senators and Maryland Attorney General
Doug Gansler are pressuring Apple and
other smartphone makers to voluntarily
block those products from their app
stores or do I say this you have a
corporate responsibility not to help
people avoid getting caught for
committing crimes blackberry maker
research in motion is the first company
to agree to the band these apps exist
because people find judgment driving
checkpoints annoying Julian Sanchez is a
senior fellow at the Cato Institute the
vast majority of drivers are not
drinking and the vast majority of
drivers resent being stopped and hassled
when they haven't done anything wrong
and for those drivers that have been
drinking these apps actually serve the
same purpose as DUI checkpoints keeping
them off the roads and the majority of
Court decisions think that DUI
checkpoints have more to do with
deterrence than they do with enforcement
Jonathan Jacques president of the
Association for competitive technology
which advocates for small tech companies
it's better to keep ten people from
getting into their car in the first
place drunk than it is to catch one guy
driving drunk right and so the more
people know the less likely they are to
actually get in the car in the first
place there's even certain jurisdictions
where the cops are the ones putting the
information into these applications if i
get my compliance without having to
write a ticket I've done my job that's
why cops in travis county texas which
includes the state capitol of austin are
collaborating with the makers of
trapster this is an information
distribution system you can only catch
one person at a time with a laser but
but you can inform
everybody on the road but even if grant
sending politicians succeeding clamping
down on free expression and pushing a
misguided and ineffective agenda all
they'll do is make life more difficult
for consumers is that whether or not you
succeeded in getting these apps band
it's it's very unlikely that you can
prevent information from spreading about
the location of these checkpoints in
fact people will use Twitter people use
the internet people will use email
people will send text messages it's
people who want to avoid the hassle one
app or another can make it easier but
it's not necessary for reason TV i'm
nick gillespie
you